gern unserem lagezentrum da probieren
wir ihn seit tagen diesen russischen
angriffskrieg ein stück weit zu erklären
wenn man das überhaupt kann aber julian
es gibt daneben auch momente und bilder
die uns beide ein stückweit sprachlos
zurücklassen muss man sagen wie das was
uns aus mario pohl erreicht ja ganz
genau wir hatten es gerade eben schon
gehört es gab gestern nachmittag diesen
unglaublichen angriff auf eine
geburtsklinik in mario pohl auf ein
krankenhaus in dem zu diesem zeitpunkt
frauen mit ihren männern natürlich waren
kinderkriegen wollten und diese klinik
wurde gestern angegriffen wahnsinn
sowohl vorher als auch nachher hat
russland diesen angriff bestätigt und
verteidigt ihn ich habe dieses bild hier
ausgesucht weil jeder der mal in so
einem moment war der in einem in einer
geburtsklinik war der weiß was das für
ein ohnehin unglaublicher moment ist und
dann fein bomben du musst rennen um dein
leben oder wie diese arme frau wirst
weggetragen moment der ganz schwer
vorstellbar ist der unerträglich ist
wenn man ihn auch nur durch denkt im
kopf und julian es gibt ein video was
diesem moment kurz nach dem angriff
zeigt was sehen wir hier ganz genau wir
sehen also die klinik quasi im innenhof
der klinik die ist so in u form
aufgebaut überall außen rum sind die
sind die gebäude
und wir sehen den wirklich moment nach
dem angriff wir sehen also die völlige
zerstörung hier im hof wir sehen dort
wie die väter also die eher männer mit
den ehefrauen und den schwangeren
ehefrauen herauskommen wie die abgeführt
oder wieder aus dem gebäude geführt
werden
und der grund dass sie überhaupt noch
leben ist das wir sehen vielleicht auch
aus verschiedenen perspektiven ist dass
die russische bombe nicht genau die
häuser getroffen hat sondern die ist
imhof explodiert hat also die ganzen
dort die ganzen fahrzeuge zerstört wir
sehen und dass das unfassbar dass von
diesem angriff so weit wir wissen das
ist ein niveau zu sagen fünf meter
tiefer krater der dort gerissen wurde
und
das ist der einzige grund weshalb wir
schwer verletzte vielleicht teilweise
auch sterbende frauen schwangere dort
sehen aber zumindest keiner kann ich
möchte gar nicht sagt keine noch
schlimmeren bilder dort gesehen haben
man sieht dass eben der erwachsene mann
der hier
in diesem gigantischen krater weil hier
eben die bombe detoniert ist und der
erde weggerissen hat natürlich um mit
der sprengkraft das gebäude zerstört hat
scheiben sind durch die gegend geflogen
haben leute verletzt wir haben hier
dieses eine bild aus dem treppenhaus wo
man eben sieht wie blutverschmierte
patienten oder eben werdende mütter sich
er probieren in sicherheit zu bringen
das ist vollkommen unvorstellbar und
wenn ich das sagen darf das ist eine der
der ddr mütter dort der den pferden
mütter die dort rein wollte es ist nicht
vorzustellen was am russischen sozialen
netzwerken gerade passiert die frau ist
die jeder junge mensch hatten instagram
profil und der wird auf grund dessen
dass sie auch bei instagram in den
monaten davor schwanger fotos gepostet
wird ihr vorgeworfen die seine
schauspielerin in russischen sozialen
medien und auch von der russischen
regierung natürlich unterstützt man sagt
dass man alles schauspieler da gab es
nur militante da gab es keine zivilisten
wird diese werdende mutter hier als eine
schauspielerin dargestellt die für
diesen angriff sozusagen extra sich
geschminkt hat und fast mal ja da gibt
es eigentlich nichts was man dazu sagen
kann außer dass das eben alles einfach
nur abartig und ein riesiges
kriegsverbrechen ist wir wollen trotzdem
verstehen kann man ist nicht aber
vielleicht versuchen zu erklären warum
diese stadt mariupol gerade so im
mittelpunkt steht und was hier drum
herum gerade passiert ja ja ja ganz
genau also mario pohl ist wenn man es
strategisch betrachtet ausgerecht drei
gründen extrem wichtig für den
russischen vorstoß zum einen und wir
sehen jetzt hier um das kurz erklären
dass rote sind sozusagen von russischen
truppen belagert und pro sich truppen
und das was in der mitte noch ist
sozusagen dieser kessel sehen wir hier
ist das was von der stadt noch übrig ist
die vorstöße ganzen eingeschlossen von
russischen vor schlüssel passieren von
allen seiten passieren einmal hier
entlang ist also auch schon mehr als im
süden passieren von norden und passieren
von osten die drei gründe die ich nennen
wollte nicht extra karte da unten das zu
erklären kann etwas für vorstöße das
sind genau damit kann man schon sehr gut
erklären einmal natürlich der grund
mario pohl ist die letzte stadt die
putin noch im wege steht um einen
landkorridor zwischen der krim und dem
russischen festland zu schaffen die krim
hat er 2014 der ukraine gestohlen hat
eine brücke gebaut aber das reicht ihm
nicht er will ein festland korridor
haben der soll hier lang gehen und wir
sehen erst eingerichtet nur mario pohl
steht ihr noch im wege der zweite grund
mario pohl ist natürlich ein
wirtschaftszentrum das wichtigste
wirtschaftszentrum am asowschen meeres
oft schon mehr ist dieses kleine mehr
nehmen super neben dem schwarzen meer
was man hier zeigen kann auch das war
putin die letzten jahre ein dorn im auge
wir erinnern uns dass er die brücke
öfter gesperrt hat das da kampfflugzeuge
lang führungen sind er möchte also
unbedingt das haben und der dritte und
letzte grund ist dass mario pohl
2014 bereits von putins schergen von den
sogenannten prorussischen separatisten
die separatisten waren sondern immer von
moskau gelenkt waren wurde 2014 schon
kurzzeitig eingenommen war einige monate
unter pro sicher kontrolle die wurden
dann zurückgeschlagen von von
ukrainischen verbänden und seitdem sagen
diese diese volksrepublik donetzk
sogenannte auch wie gesagt alles kreml
marionetten sagen wir wollen mario pohl
haben das ist eine wichtige stadt für
uns deshalb sehen wir den vorsprung vor
den den angriff auch von beiden seiten
also die sogenannten separatisten mit
extremen unterstützung der russischen
armee dringen von osten und norden auf
die stadt vor
während die russische armee von von
westen auf die stadt vordringen gibt es
für diese stadt wenn wir noch mal
probieren auf die stadt selbst zurück zu
schauen gibt es für diese stadt noch
irgendeine chance oder ist es eine frage
der zeit bis die stadt fallen wird ich
selbst habe mario pohl besucht vor zwei
jahren und muss sagen ich wundere mich
dass sie so lange durchhält die stadt
also tatsächlich die die ehemalige
frontlinie
der ehemalige frontlinie verlief etwa im
hinterzimmer
verlief etwa hier das heißt das war
alles auch ukrainisch gehalten das ist
jetzt nicht mehr so dass von den russen
kontrolliert die war extrem stark in der
stadt selber habe ich nicht viel militär
gesehen sind ganz normale riesige stadt
also 450.000 einwohner ungefähr
vergleichbar dem deutschen großstädten
der wenn man so möchte zivile teil ist
hier und der riesige wirtschaftsteil
nämlich die ganze industrie ist ist hier
angesiedelt
wieland ich konnte es mir nicht
vorstellen dass das so lange hält es
sind offenbar sehr sehr
sage ich mal bilden starke verteidiger
dort auch teilweise der ukrainische
national guard vom regiment azoff was
ein
nationalistisches element ist ja nicht
die nationalgarde und die haben schon
gesagt sie werden bis zum letzten
tropfen kämpfen dass uns zum abschluss
noch einmal zurückkommen auf dieses
ikonische bild was bleiben wird von
diesem angriffskrieg du begleitet ist
putins angriffskrieg in der ganzen
region in syrien schon so lange hast so
lange darüber berichtet ist dieses bild
für dich überraschend oder ist das etwas
auf das wir uns alle gefasst sein
mussten weil eben putin genauso seine
kriege führt für mich persönlich ist es
überhaupt nicht überraschend ich glaube
wir bei bild haben seit dezember gewarnt
vor russlands krieg gegen die ukraine
und wir haben auch von vornherein gesagt
was es werden soll nämlich ein
vernichtungskrieg wir wurden dafür sehr
kritisiert das könnte man nicht
gleichsetzen mit irgendwas anderem das
wären historische parallelen die man
nicht ziehen darf ich glaube wer sich
ansieht was putins armee seit september
2016 in syrien macht also seit sechs
jahren in syrien macht nämlich gezielt
krankenhäuser angreifen gezielt schulen
an greifen gezielt wasserversorgung
zerstören der weiß dass russlands
vormarsch wenn er nicht so geht wie
putin möchte nämlich freiwillig in
anspruch stechen er geht in die städte
rein und alles ist in ordnung dann
gleich das einen vernichtungskrieg gegen
die zivilbevölkerung und genau den sehen
wir jetzt ganz gerade besonders an mario
pohl den sehen wir und vermutlich werden
wir auch noch mehr davon sehen müssen
juli an ich danke dir sehr für diese
analyse